i
[Música]
el 3 de junio de 1986 cayó un aguacero
tremendo en la ciudad de mexico me
acuerdo bien porque ese día
cumplí 10 años mi mamá preparo una pizza
jugué con mis amigos super nintendo
y me comí un delicioso pastel de
chocolate
ese día fue muy especial para mí me
regalaron juguetes por acá juguetes por
acá pero recibí quizás el regalo que ha
cambiado mi vida mi papá me dio un sobre
y adentro de sobre ese sobre había había
un cheque y el cheque decía
parece a nombre de patricio villalobos
cuevas la cantidad vale por todos los
partidos para ver en ciudad
universitaria en el estadio azteca y en
el azulgrana a tu equipo favorito
yo no sabía que ese cheque me iba a
cambiar la vida pero así fue
tuve la gran oportunidad de vivir un año
todos los partidos del mejor equipo de
esta galaxia los pumas de la universidad
nacional autonoma de mexico
goya
la verdad es que el fútbol de chicos
siempre me ha gustado me acuerdo ese año
cuando cumplí los 10 ese verano de 1986
cuando se dio el mundial en méxico y mi
mamá me regaló el pan y ni ese pan y ni
que tenías que agarrar el pri chupar la
que pegar la estampita las colecciones
todas las tardes me acuerdo las tardes
de los domingos me acuerdo que mi mamá
me decía patricio ya métete a la casa ya
me tiré porque hay que hacer tarea o
porque hay que ir a dormir yo le decía
espérame un momentito quiero seguir
jugando y ya que estaba en la casa los
domingos y con la angustia de que al
otro día iba a tener una clase le decía
déjame de las repeticiones de este
programa que conduce josé ramón
fernández
si yo pudiera entrar a mi cabeza y
escoger una imagen de ese 1986 de ese
verano mágico
creo que podría agarrar esta imagen en
donde yo llego un poco calladito porque
mi abuelo está serio a punto de ver el
partido yo prendo la tele y en la tele
veo esta imagen veo a un lugo sánchez
que pierde la pelota en el centro del
campo se la pasa rafael amador rafael
amador no sé cómo le hace promete un
centro perfecto que negrete dribla se la
pasa aguirre aguirre se la regresa
negrete y un gol el segundo mejor gol de
toda la historia en ese momento pensaba
yo que era el primer gol el mejor gol de
la historia hoy creo que es el segundo
mejor gol de la historia y ya verán por
qué
el fútbol me gustó siempre
y yo deseaba trabajar en esto y el
destino me llevó para allá estudié
ciencias computacionales tuve la fortuna
de estar becado en alemania y en
alemania cuando el internet en el 97
sonaba
en ese momento yo quería saber cómo iba
mi equipo y lo que hice fue
hacer un programita mandárselo a mi
primo y mi primo en casa en mexico veía
el partido ya sea en la tele yendo al
estadio
llegaba a su casa se mete a la compu se
metía a internet y me escribía patricio
como siempre volvimos a ganar
américa 1 pumas 3 mis compañeros en la
escuela en alemania me dijeron oye está
padrísimo esto avísame cómo quedó
también chivas como quedó tigres como
quedo rayados como quedó la américa y
entonces ahí detecte a una oportunidad
de negocio una oportunidad que tal vez
me iba a hacer estar cerca de lo que yo
más quería
tuve la grandísima fortuna que al
regresar de alemania me encontré con dos
personas que han marcado mi vida miguel
y sergio mis socios que hoy cumplo en
este este año cumplo 20 años con ellos
la fortuna me junto comparto valores y
comparto ilusiones con ellos el 7 de
febrero del año 2000 lanzamos esta
chulada de portal mediotiempo.com un
portal que entretenía e informaba un
portal en donde subíamos todas las
noticias para decir a la gente y estos
son los resultados o esta es la mejor
transacción del momento el negocio
simplemente era que mucha gente entrara
para vender mucha publicidad
así es como trabajamos
y con la fuerza de la escuela dijimos
que si vamos a emprender este negocio
vamos a ponernos una misión una visión y
un organigrama pude rescatar el primer
organigrama que pudimos tener un
organigrama en donde si no mal veo el
48% de la empresa son directores y los
demás tienen
por favor vean el título del director de
enlaces que significa ser director de
enlaces no lo sé miguel tampoco sabe hoy
qué significaba eso
en fin con la ilusión salimos con una
misión informar y entretener a todos los
aficionados en américa latina' a los
aficionados al deporte más hermoso del
mundo salimos y lanzamos medio tiempo
empezamos a tener 10 20 30 100 visitas
al día 5.000 10.000 pero de pronto el
año 2001 la burbuja de internet las
empresas no podían sostener las
valuaciones que tenían y explotar de
haber ganado cierta cantidad de dinero
pasamos
yo tenía que pagar la beca de la escuela
y para eso me tuve que emplear me fui a
hacer algoritmos que encontraban
patrones ilícitos de comportamiento de
las aduanas del país imagínense yo creía
que podía hacer algo por méxico ahí me
hice muy astuto en las bases de datos
pero yo creía que había algo importante
y algo que me faltaba realmente hacer lo
que yo quería
tuve oportunidad en octubre del año 2002
un amigo me invitó a buenos aires y me
dijo si te gusta pumas y sientes que
cuando canta la rebel esa joya que
retumba y retumba no vas a creer lo que
pasa cuando se genera un boca-river y
dije vamos
llegué y fue algo que me regreso a donde
yo quería estar
y que me demostró que se hacía lo que yo
quería siempre siempre la historia iba a
salir a mi favor ahí empecé a escuchar
cánticos que yo no escuchaba en méxico y
uno de ellos que si pudiera ser un
contrato acá lo tengo por eso es bello
el fútbol imagínense este contrato por
una parte el aficionado que le dice por
este amor yo te aliento de la cuna hasta
el cajón porque yo dejo todo para verte
salir campeón así le decía a la gente a
sus jugadores y por otra parte en este
contrato de yo doy algo tú también
tienes que dar algo
el jugador decía pero tu jugador tú
tienes que dejar la vida por estos
colores
el jugador que deje la vida por estos
yo escuchaba esos cánticos pero cuando
entré al estadio y escuché algo como así
[Aplausos]
pero
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tenía que regresar al fútbol a quien de
aquí no se le ha puesto la piel chinita
al escuchar esto
regrese al fútbol
y encontré cinco formas de emprender y
creo que son la receta perfecta para
lograr el éxito
la primera es armar un equipo fabuloso
una gente que te acompañe siempre que
esa gente tenga fuerza que tenga
capacidad de decisión capacidad de hacer
un cambio esta foto tiene tres sillas
eran los tres cubículos que rentamos en
el sótano de una oficina en el sur de la
ciudad de mexico
walter el primer editor general de medio
tiempo trabajaba yo creo que trescientos
noventa días al año esta foto la tomamos
a las tres de la mañana de un sábado
para un domingo
gente que de nada va a su vida por esto
gente creativa como por ejemplo nuestro
departamento de marketing que saber que
no teníamos dinero para pautar en la
tele o en el periódico decía pues porque
no ponemos una pancarta y en el mundial
de alemania les decimos visiten medio
tiempo y que creen la gente nos visitaba
gente muy creativa un equipo que iba
creciendo y que se generaba un
ecosistema positivo porque porque
sabíamos que informábamos y entre
teníamos a la gente siempre con el
deporte más hermoso del mundo llegamos a
hacer 100 hasta que un día magnesio me
habla y yo estoy cruzando la línea que
me cruza de tijuana-san diego y me dice
aparto está sentado y sé que hay un
servidor seguro que paso mike nos
quieren comprar
era el 2008 podíamos anunciar que
prácticamente un millón de personas nos
visitaban todos los días un millón de
mexicanos entrando a una marca que había
sido generada por tres emprendedores
mexicanos y un equipazo nos compró time
esta empresa multinacional
en ese momento la empresa de medios más
grande del mundo yo jugaba es decir que
el medio tiempo era primo de cnn y casi
hermano de harry potter
en el emprendimiento nos dimos cuenta
también que hay que adaptarse al cambio
al principio hicimos una página que era
para meterte en la computadora pero
después vimos que los celulares eran
fuertes y que la gente empezaba a
navegar con el pulgar y que twitter y
facebook nos decían y nos dictaban cómo
era el comunicar la información vimos
que la gente empezaba a compartir
emociones y dijimos sabes qué
los jóvenes van a consumir bolt de otra
manera y tenemos que reinventarnos
un joven no te va a leer una nota así
una nota larga con un texto no lo va a
hacer un joven si le quieres explicar
que argentina tiene cuatro bajas para
enfrentar a méxico pues mejor haces una
infografía que se la pongas en su
twitter o en su instagram o en su
facebook y así vas a tener relevancia
hoy este proyecto fabuloso que se llama
juan fútbol llegan 30 millones de
mexicanos todos los días
emprender
es resiliencia es adaptarse no solamente
al cambio sino saber separar después de
tanta batalla porque vas a creer una y
mil veces y esta imagen la pongo porque
emprender es
sé que hay en los servidores la pauta
creativa nos sirve el cliente te la
cambio al último minuto o la que tanto
nos duele el dinero está a punto de
acabarse y no tenemos con qué pagar la
nómina pero siempre fuimos residentes y
aunque nos quedaba un cachito de vida
hacemos magia para sacar esa patada y
poder salir adelante
creo que emprender también es tener un
foco fuerte y no soltarlo nunca nosotros
supimos que queríamos el fútbol y que lo
queríamos comunicar este es una foto
yo todavía tenía pelo y estaba
transmitiendo un partido de fútbol
estaba comunicando
hoy debo decir que hago fútbol porque me
recuerda mis días de infancia porque
genera un ecosistema siempre positivo
tenemos un proyecto fabuloso que dijimos
ya estamos contando las historias del
mes y ya contamos las historias de pumas
pero qué pasa con el fútbol más
relevante el que más nos importa a todos
cuál es
es el que yo juego los sábados con mis
amigos es el que mi hijo juega los
viernes con sus equipos
entonces dijimos tratemos a ellos como
si fuesen profesionales
y agustín el primo que me mandaba los
mensajes así quién sabe cuántos años se
convirtió en el mejor fotógrafo en
mexico y tomaba estas fotos y decía es
que esto es profesional
trata este niño como si fuese de
cristiano o sacan la emoción de este
niño que acaba de meter un gol y
comunica la a sus papás a sus tíos y a
todo el mundo y eso es lo que estamos
haciendo
y por último quiero este es un tema un
poco personal la verdad es que nunca lo
he hecho
quiero dedicar esta plática como en el
quinto punto de emprendimiento quiero
hablar de no dudes
formamos en este emprendimiento miguel
sergio y yo y un día sergio me dice
pato me duele la cabeza yo como que pasó
tenemos una junta importante pero es que
me duele mucho la cabeza
tenía un tumor en la cabeza y en un año
nuestro socio querido con el que
compartíamos más de 15 horas todos los
días se fue
y hoy le quiero dedicar a él esta
plática porque nunca lo he hecho y nunca
le he dicho gracias porque cuando lo fui
a vamos a ver la última vez al hospital
me senté con él
y él en un momento raro de lucidez me
dijo la ciencia no da más por mí pero
vino un médico cubano y me dijo a qué te
dedicas yo le conté que hacíamos una
página de internet que hablaba de fútbol
y entonces me empezó a curar me decía
kobe
y al final un poco antes de ese volteo y
me dijo ay muchacho no dude esa página
va a ser grande
y sergio me decía joven pato no dudes
esto va a ser grande y si hoy le pudiera
decir algo a él
le diría como aquellas tardes cuando
convivíamos y se hacía muy noche y su
mamá creía que trabajaba él en un bar
y yo le diría que nunca dudamos y que
las cosas se puso buena que tengo tres
hijos preciosos y que juegan fútbol y
que un día en el centro al parque un
mago y les dijo
qué hacen jugando ahí quieren jugar un
juego de magia y desde dijeron sí y
mateo lewin y ccoo encontraron un premio
y ese premio era el sueño de ir a un
mundial tres chamacos llevándolos a
russia imagínense nada más práctico y te
quiero decir
que el gol no es el de manuel negrete el
gol más perfecto es el que quitaron mis
hijos con tanta fuerza el que gritaron
en la cta grada del luzhnikí en moscú
y que lo gritaron fuerte ese golazo de
chuck y alemania
ese golazo de chucky que lo ustedes lo
recuerdan o le ganamos uno observa
alemania como si hubiésemos ganado la
copa del mundo
y recuerdo que llegamos de vuelta al
hotel y en el hotel yo me metí a ver
todas las repeticiones posibles vi el
gol en turco en ruso en croata lo narró
el perro lo narró martinoli y encontré
una narración que yo creo que era kobe
diciendo media vez no tenías que dudar y
les pido que escuchen esta narración
atacante mira bien por detrás del frente
sacamos el chicharito
el chícharo
está
[Aplausos]
pégale chuck y no dudes
y eso es lo que les quiero decir a ti
kobe también te lo digo nunca dudamos y
por eso es que la rompimos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]